what is going on there citizens of the reject
nation greg john how are you i'm great how are
you i am okay you look great that's what i like
to hear pushing through and what you guys can
push through to do is what can they do with this
thumb oh they can put it up they can leave a like
this is called back and forth learn how to do it
the key to chemistry on camera this is cheering
each other's questions hey all right guys we
got two pieces of marvel to talk about that
marvel train does not stop rolling in after this
weekend so much marvel for the next couple years
so much breaking news so much information so much
so that we're gonna be a day late to it just like
today we gotta talk about some x-men updates some
major x-men updates and we gotta talk about a
major avengers kang dynasty update as well two
things i'm sure you've already heard about but
if you haven't stick around and if you already
have who knows we might say something that's
slightly different or more of the same that
everyone else has said that's where you got
to stick around to find out x-men so here's the
main update there's this report that's been going
around that you could hear more details about but
the basic summary goes like this whoever played a
character within the fox x-men universe no one can
contractually replace that actor that character
until 2025 or after so you know take ty sheridan
everyone's favorite cyclops everyone's like
yeah that's my cyclops no one can replace thai
sheridan never right now but that also explains
why you can get like patrick stewart at least to
cameo as professor x and multiverse of madness
evan peters to not quite be quicksilver but sort
of probably because of all these rights but then
it makes you question like maybe that's why they
had kamala khan changed to be a spoiler a mutant
versus an inhuman now it's making me really
believe the theories that have been going
around about how you know they they're probably
going to be gearing up to do a mutants movie
first before they actually do an x-men movie
like they very well could just wait until 2025
or after because it's kind of making me ponder is
this why they're churning out so many properties
over the next couple years so they can really
finally do x-men the way how everyone's been
demanding and wanting i say that and the other
part of me goes well they could just you know
spread out their properties a little bit more
and just weave the x-men in between but they got
a specific plan they got to adhere by so i don't
know what the reasoning might be but that doesn't
mean that we wouldn't be able to possibly
still see some fox x-men characters within
something like avengers secret wars this is the
multiverse saga after all is it not humphrey it
is officially as of this weekend so with it being
the multiverse saga you could very well have some
cool cameos in something like secret wars or
even king dynasty where characters come together
former ones hugh jackman 65 years old because he
will have aged 20 years in the next two yep and
or one of the other x-men characters so that way
you do have the ultimate collision of all these
characters so you still get some mutants and you
know this news might bum people out because they
gotta wait a little bit longer to hear something
truly official however the mutants universe is so
massive and that's been one of the biggest things
to theorize and why a lot of people have thought
they're just gonna smash together some universes
because of the fact of how vast and how much it
would change the world to have mutants within it
i'm like well you got a bunch of other characters
you can pull from to make a mutant's movie without
having to pull from the fox x-men ones and that
way it's even more rewarding when the patience
pays off by the time you get to 2026 where it's
just two straight years of x-men well that's what
i was thinking because at first you see phase six
there's so many open slots and some of them are in
2025 and you're like oh that's where the mutants
are going but they say you know probably they
can't even use or shoot anything even in advance
until after that window is over so i almost feel
like yeah you could pay homage to the classic
20th century x-men roster then after your big
secret wars event you can close that universe
out officially finally send off any last threads
that need it or deserve it and then you can start
fresh with a really sort of x-men centric phase
seven yeah give sophie turner one last shot at
being a dark phoenix one more dark phoenix some
more dark phoenix thrown in there yeah that's
the updates of that wanted to be a little more
patient they got a lot of properties right now
there's always a conversation of quantity over
quality with marvel i definitely think you know
let them handle their projects and then we'll get
our x-men and we'll be happy the next one uh won't
take as long to explain but it is exciting you
know we were talking in our live stream about
you know who might the directors possibly be for
avengers king dynasty and avengers secret wars
easy to theorize that whoever they got for kang
dynasty would do secret wars now did they confirm
that this individual would be the one who would do
secret wars as well or is it only being reported
for king dinosaur believe it's only killing the
only report i've seen is specifically kang dynasty
right now so who's being reported right now and we
saw this on the hollywood reporter to be directing
avengers kang dynasty we had been theorizing this
is not one of the names we threw out there but we
were speculating that it would be a director who's
helmed one of these movies from phase four through
phase six they would go you know what they're
doing they knew how to do the movie like the
way they did with russo brothers and then let's
have them direct it and we're going to be getting
chloe's to finish each other's sentences yeah yeah
dustin daniel [__] this destin daniel creden who
i think did an incredible job when i was thinking
about the movies that we've gotten so far within
the mcu that has one of the better ensemble
films like the whole ensemble really shines
protagonist antagonists some side characters here
they're like the world was truly fleshed out and
they introduced so many new people in such a new
world i think destin daniel credit really nailed
it like it's not one of my favorite mcu films that
has some of my favorite action out of the mcu and
there's a lot of things that i would consider like
favorite qualities of the mcu however i think for
a first film and then to introduce so many things
versus what the russo brothers did which was
carrying on a character who was already introduced
in two prior movies i think he did an excellent
job i think what he displayed there definitely
shows yeah i think he can pull off an avengers
level movie for sure especially with what he did
with scale action cast and then he wouldn't have
to the worry of having to introduce a bunch of
new people either he can literally work with the
machine who knows maybe he'll get fired to replace
that you know how these things go as far as it
goes i think he's a solid solid pick it would be
interesting if they got one director for dynasty
and then different director for a secret wars
yeah i think that could be actually a really cool
collaborative thing where yeah it's like clearly
this installment is by this director but clearly
they also coordinated it could easily work out
that he does both but i almost wonder if they're
going to film them simultaneously or something and
have basically two units running yeah it's not the
name i threw out and i wish i had because thinking
back it's the movie i think of when i go that
movie had so much to do chongqi it had so much
to introduce it has so much to juggle and manage
while still telling something of an emotionally
resonant and impactful story yeah and i feel like
with the amount of world building and balancing
that movie is like cranked to the extreme in
terms of the economics of time and pacing but i
feel like of all the movies i've seen thus far in
phase four that is the one i point to and i'm like
for what they had to cram into that amount of time
that's like about the smoothest i could imagine it
being given the circumstances and so yeah he seems
like a really solid choice on all fronts managing
the immense chaos but also bringing some of that
emotional weight because you know there's gonna
be some heavier stuff coming especially as we
get into phase six and i think that's a perfect
territory for him one problem with it he's not
white you know that's the man i don't know if he
can really handle it you know because we've had
three white people helm the other avengers movies
and i just think you know you you don't want to
fix let's get peyton read let's just stay safe and
get peyton reed to direct both of the ends of the
don't try to fix what ain't broken you know that's
just what i'm saying that's what i'm saying i feel
like there's a strong correlation between it white
marvel white marvel all the way um anyway guys
what do you think about them getting
an asian guy to direct avengers gang
half those characters aren't asian like why would
they need his i don't understand this doesn't make
sense does it make sense we riot no not my not
my kang did you get the point what do you what
do you guys think about this x-men news is it a
bummer to you what do you guys think about destin
daniel crown do you think he's the right pick for
avengers king dynasty leave your thoughts down
below please do subscribe click that notification
bell leave a like and hey let's end this with a
jean jeter it's another comican but even more
than that my friend your birthday is coming up
my dude so i thought who better to shout out on
a comic-con video is it wakanda forever maybe i
don't know yet i don't know it's coming out man
but i do know that you are a mensch and i'm glad
that you're here with us and uh hey leave me uh
you know a charming voice message in your inbox
and uh keep doing what you do i'm looking forward
uh you know to the next real rejects cringe laugh
compilation quantomania station what a marvel
it will be puns puns love you buddy be well